alors on a on a nous a beaucoup parlé de
barack obama ce week end avec jean luc
lemoine ce que nous sommes allés en
belgique ensemble pour participer au
télévie exactement et jean luc lemoine
sachet de a failli perdre un doigt
revoilà on vous raconte tout c'est vrai
mais en tout cas il faut ça qu'on a eu
la chance d'être dans l'hôtel de bahreïn
dit où était passé barack obama ouais
depuis ce week-end maintenant 10 et
l'hôtel où est passée cyril hanouna
mais jean luc lemoine s'est coincé le
doigt voulons vous racontent tour il a
failli perdre un doigt et je suis monté
dans un taxi et j'ai mis ma main et le
garçon qui était devant a eu la bonne
idée de claquer des doigts et j'ai eu
mon doigt coincé dans l'avion c'est à
dire que j'étais en train de mourir
vraiment et l'autre était mort de rire
et là j'ai eu cette phrase je lui dis
franchement qc un doigt big island a
besoin 4
[Applaudissements]